all right cool all right well we are
live hello everyone i am with uh jen
calendar and she is a sleep coach
consultant for
for kids and babies helping parents get
through that process and we were
connected through our mutual friend
right lionel that's right yes
uh
i guess he recommended me to you i don't
know how it ended up working out but um
i guess everybody watching you want to
give a quick intro
i did i did like it two seconds but tell
us a little bit more about who you are
what you're all about
sure so uh i call myself a uh child
sleep consultant
so basically what that means is i help
with behavioral sleep issues so it could
be the baby that's not sleeping through
the night you know it's still eight ten
months of age
it could be um
the toddler that needs to transition out
of a nap or it could be the preschooler
that's still sleeping in mom and dad's
bed and parents are looking to kick them
out
got it what got you into that business
uh it's kind of a complicated story um i
am i'm actually a chartered accountant
and
i went to business school i went to the
richard ivory school of business
uh because i always wanted to own a
business um just didn't really know when
what and i'm not very creative couldn't
think of any business ideas so i went to
business school and decided uh to become
a chartered accountant so i could learn
business through financial statements um
sort of that side of things so i got my
designation uh and worked for magna for
five years so
i lived north of the city worked for
magna
and then i had lots of babies
i got married i have three kids i have a
daughter she's five and twin sons
they're just over two
so uh the twins weren't sleeping very
well so i spent a lot of time getting
them to be great sleepers
and uh also knew that going back to work
was going to be a real real challenge
um and i had that moment where
you know i could see myself in 20 years
still being an accountant and you know
regretting not
you know getting into business which is
what i originally wanted to do so
i had a epiphany i guess about two years
ago
and where we are
very cool so so what can i help you with
well um i'm a relatively new business i
mean it's uh 18 months old now um so far
this year i'm on track
to quadruple what i've done last year
right um but you know i'm here by myself
i have limited resources and limited
time and you know i struggle with you
know what do i focus on and what's
um you know the best
best place to spend my time and
resources i guess
um you know there's all that networking
you know
mommy groups and you know
advertising budgets you know how much do
you spend on certain things
um so i don't know if you have any
insight into you know this kind of
service industry and and what you'd
recommend
so you're focused now you're trying to
get new customers
new customers i mean a lot of the
customers that i've had because it works
so well
it's all based on the science of sleep
so you know there's lots to back it up
um because it works so well they're all
telling their friends which is great so
a lot of word-of-mouth
um but you know a lot of my customers
aren't repeat customers they may come
back for one or two little issues but
i'm looking for new customers all the
time so you know it's constant sales
and on a limited budget you can't really
hire somebody to to do that for me at
this point
yeah no yeah i love the idea
when you come in
is it like a weekend and you're done or
is it
does it take longer than that how does
it usually work with a customer
well i do different things uh my most
popular package is you know a 60 to 90
minute hour consultation either on the
phone skype or in their home
and that's to just go over their plan so
i create a plan for them
we go over get the questions answered uh
tweak it you know as we go to make them
comfortable with it and once we sign off
on that i provide two weeks of follow-up
support unlimited email phone texting
for two weeks to help them implement
um so that's the most popular i also do
overnights so i'll just go into the home
for six to 12 hours overnight and give
hands-on support if that's what they'd
like and then again the two weeks
following
and then
is it solved in that overnight or that
one hour call and they do the work or
is there silly shoes ongoing
um yeah it's
it's usually in the two weeks of
follow-up support where you see the real
success so you know they get motivated
when you give them the plan they think
yeah you know i can do this but it's
sort of like personal training i equate
myself to you know you can get the
workout plan but unless you go to the
gym unless you have somebody motivating
you to do the work um it often just you
know
you don't form that new habit so you
don't uh you don't lose the weight you
don't get into shape so you know i'm
there to sort of breathe down their neck
keep them on track answer questions
troubleshoot
um
you know be their punching bag too a lot
of the time i'm uh
i'm their punching bag so
it's hard man i remember going through
that when my son
was uh four months old getting him to
sleep through the night and not
you know have to go in every hour to
feed him it's it's it's uh as a parent
you feel really guilty when they're
crying and it's hard it is hard
so
i
you're providing a great service
how much does it cost so the one hour
call with the with the the two weeks
follow up versus the uh
overnight
uh so the phone call is 350
and that gets you your plan the two
weeks of unlimited support the
consultation and then i actually send
you away with uh information at the end
to help you with travel illness you know
things that come up down the road um the
overnight for six hours is 8.95
and that includes everything but in
addition to the six hours of the
overnight and 12 hours overnight is
13.95
and i guess the phone call you could do
anywhere right
yeah
yeah i've had lots of clients all over
canada so i've had some in vancouver
some in quebec
um all over ontario so you know it's
yeah it's great i could technically go
on vacation and do my calls as well
do you know what your success rate is
uh it's high it's between 95 and 99. um
i've only had a few clients drop off
mainly because they wanted to take a
different route naturopath that kind of
thing
um
yeah and i mean if children get sick we
put everything on hold and then you know
we start up again when the child is
healthy again so
you know i'm not a big stickler for the
two weeks it's not it doesn't have to be
exactly 14 days
and i have
considered you know sort of offering a
guarantee an official one
um but you know parents do have their uh
you know their questions and they wonder
if it works and
so you know i do tell parents that if
they are completely unsatisfied you know
i'll make sure that they are whether
that's giving their money back offering
them more time
um you know i want them to be successful
as well
yeah
do you have a website that talks about
all this
yeah
lionel actually built my website so uh
all right
it's beautiful it's uh www.babyz.com
which is sorry i'm lying
baby babysies.ca uh so it's b a b y z
zed dot ca
ah cool okay baby zed said that that ca
okay i'll check it out um
so
you look at typical service-based
businesses
honestly
the way most people build it up and get
to the point where
they have enough business just for
themselves is through great service and
word of mouth
if you are really good at what you do
and you provide an amazing service
people do talk about you and people
spread the message and and
moms spread the message
if they love something they talk dads do
too but moms especially they love the
talk
uh
you you can look at any service based
business and if the stage where you're
at right now you're not
you're a one-person show right and that
may be i don't know if you want to grow
this beyond if you want to
franchise it or have a team or whatever
but for a one person show typically the
best way to do it is by providing
amazing service and getting word of
mouth and i'd honestly focus on not so
much worrying about the advertising like
advertising is a
brutal expensive way to grow it you
could do the mommy groups you could do
the expert thing and have a twitter
account and share blog content and all
that but your best bet honestly is going
to be
investing into the relationship with
your clients and making them say
wow like we cannot live without this
woman
so it sounds like your success rate is
pretty high it sounds like you're
already getting some referrals which is
great i think about what else can you do
in that process to either make it easier
at the start for them to get results
um reduce their
anxiety or risk
you know if it's just being i mean
you're very friendly it's great
personable easy to talk to
um
you love videos
you're all into the videos is that
something that i should maybe get into
is more video content so people can sort
of meet me
i love videos and you're very personable
and
you know you you look great on camera
you could do a simple video and have
that on your website i mean i'm on your
website now it has your face it's great
i love the logo
uh you know it looks professional you're
on you know all this media which is
great
um you know you can tell you had a
professional do it so lionel good job if
he's gonna watch this eventually um
you can it helps i mean the more
personal you can make it
tell your story how you've gone through
with uh with your two twins and and what
happened and telling stories about moms
um you know you had you had something
here success stories on your home page
i don't know if that's actually the
person it looks kind of like a stock
photography thing but um
it's all great like the website is it is
good a lot of people who are in this
business
um have terrible websites
and have no presents and have no videos
and are not on twitter
but
you honestly don't as much as i love
that stuff
if your goal is just to get to the point
where you are like how many clients
could you take on at a time um typically
i mean i could probably take up to 10 a
week but you know right now i'm getting
about four or five a week
also i mean you're not that far away 10
a week
that's new clients
yes yes 10 new clients a week because
then you're
you're supporting them and the two weeks
the two weeks is usually by email
usually by email yeah the odd text and
phone call here and there
and what's your end goal with this do
you want this to be a big thing do you
want to franchise it you want to have a
team or this is a home business for you
and
what do you want to do with this thing
my trouble is i get bored easily
there
so um you know my mom always says you
really like to make things interesting
so i don't know if i could do things as
i'm doing it now forever so yes i think
i'd like to grow and you know build my
team and work with others and um you
know because right now i do feel a bit
alone in the whole process and you know
it'd be great to be able to bounce ideas
off others and you know my husband's
great he just you know doesn't want to
hurt my feelings ever so it's always yes
yes that's amazing good idea but really
you know
um
so so yeah for sure i mean when i first
started this business that was my goal
let's franchise this let's make it a a
big thing and you know hiring a sleep
consultant would be as natural as you
know going to your doctor almost like
everybody needs one because sleep is so
important so you know that is my goal so
that
you know everybody knows that we exist
because that's a big problem too
um you know that that service even
exists and uh you know for it to become
normal
to hire somebody
yeah so typically this is how service
companies branch out again at the
beginning you can build this thing if
you make it amazing if your service is
awesome if you're really good at what
you do and people are talking you can
build this
to get your 10 clients a week just
through word of mouth and invest in
those relationships that will happen
naturally if you're doing a good job
when you look at people who have
service-based businesses people who are
really good
and they have all the business they need
for themselves it's been through word of
mouth and may not have a website or it's
a crappy one it doesn't matter because
word of mouth spreads
but then if you want to grow beyond the
two paths that people usually take
one is to continue down the service
route
and
you you can start increasing your prices
right so maybe it's not three something
per call it's five something per call
because because you're so much in demand
you can only take 10 clients
per week right so then
your prices you'll reach a point where
okay this is really the max this is
like i'm getting tons of feedback that
nobody will go beyond this point um
but there are some people who are like
seen as the world's experts on
these things and they host workshops and
people flying from
around north america to meet them and
help them um i remember there was one i
was even looking at for uh
getting my son out of diapers that was
like oh wow
that's a that was a nightmare how to get
him out of diapers and it was this
clinic happening in somewhere in the u.s
and i almost like flew down there just
to solve this problem right like parents
do crazy things it's
you know when you're not sleeping and
anyway so
you know you fill up your roster by
providing great service you can start
increasing your prices
you reach a point then where you decide
and a lot of people just stay there like
i'm making a good income i'm making my
whatever it is
you know it could be 50k a year 100k a
year 200k a year whatever it is just as
you could do that you can you can if you
look at good consultants
like in more in the business world but
you look at good consultants you can
make two to three hundred thousand
dollars a year
solo entrepreneur as a consultant just
from word of mouth marketing because
you're really good and you've built up
your approvals and for a lot of people
that's enough like if i'm working
part-time and i'm making a hundred
thousand dollars a year
that's good for a lot of people
if that's not good for you like you say
god you know what two years i'm gonna be
i'm gonna be bored and i need to grow
this out
two common ways to do it one is you
bring on a team so
you're now the senior sleep consultant
and you bring on the junior seat
consultant right that's typically the
first way to do it you're a senior
consultant you know if you look at
traditional consulting companies senior
consultant and then junior consultant
underneath or if you're a personal
training company you know senior trainer
junior trainer with different pricing
um
or you go product
so a lot of people say hey you know what
i really love doing my consulting gig
and i would never give it up i'd never
do i never i never want to go down to
zero days a week i still want to keep
one or two days a week in my practice
but i want to leverage my time by
creating product so
you turn your one hour phone call into
mp3s
and sell that with a guide and
worksheets and you systemize i mean you
have your system so you turn it into an
e-product that people can
and buy
right
and so then you're not spending any time
on
maintaining those relationships you have
to put the time as a fixed cost into
creating your product and then you
once it's sold it's just money each time
yeah
both of those plans
are much bigger and can build you a much
bigger business than just
your you know
75 to 250k a year solo practice
um
it's a special personality that wants to
go out and do that because a lot of
people
in that situation if you become the one
of the best at what you do you're making
a good income
that's enough for them
uh so it's really a question for you if
you think you're going to get bored and
you want to build this thing up and you
want to have a team or you want to
create product
then it's worth thinking about more the
marketing
stuff now right so having a youtube
channel and having your twitter and
being seen as an expert an authority
right if if uh cnn has
a story on
baby sleeping you should be the person
that they call right you're reading
content and be seen as that expert
you're engaging with people
um
but it depends on what your ultimate
goal is right if you want to be that
expert if you want to build that brand
that's a that's definitely a way to do
it if you just want to help moms and
have a you know major impact on a few
people and have a nice
income then
that's another way to do it
does that make sense
absolutely yeah that absolutely makes
sense and uh
i think i you know the
struggle is you know family life too so
i do have all these young kids
and while i'd love to reach for the
stars tomorrow it may be a case of
getting more comfortable
with the business as it is now
with the
uh goal of growing it and building these
youtube channels and all these things
you talk about now
um for that moment when i do want to go
big
are you i mean it also depends on where
you are
financially you are you guys stretch
like you need this business to take off
for you guys to have your
lifestyle as a family or this is
like a bonus and you can afford to
invest the time decreasing maybe not
spend a lot of money but invest the time
into building
a brand up
uh it depends on the day my husband's
also self-employed
so you know we may have an awesome month
it may be um where you're like oh we're
a little bit stretched so yeah yeah it
does vary i would say we're probably
more on the stretch side of things at
the moment just because we both sort of
launched our businesses a few years ago
so
um
so the brand building stuff takes time
right it doesn't have to cost money but
it takes time you need to
you need to build yourself up as an
authority you need to
you know be on twitter and create
content and make videos and part of it
is you
allowing time for momentum to build
right you don't get a lot off of one
video you gotta keep creating lots of
videos
and the second part is you getting
better at it right like your first video
is gonna take you the whole day to do
and it's probably to suck like you're
going to look at it and say oh man
i don't want to put this up i feel so
embarrassed i remember my first videos i
i look back on them now and cringe at
how bad i i feel i am on the video
it's just a muscle like anything else it
takes a lot of time to develop to start
getting good
uh i've done over a thousand videos on
my youtube channel and just in the last
hundred
uh actually can watch what i'm doing and
be proud
cringe
yeah i mean it takes a long time and so
that's time you're not spending you know
working with customers and getting
referrals and improving your process but
it helps you with the bigger picture
longer term stuff so if you're if you're
kind of stretched or crunched
i would focus right now on the referrals
and the relationships with your clients
and think how can you
just do an overwhelming amazing job with
each mom that comes in and make them
feel
at home
answer any questions you could do the
the guarantee
because they should be if you're really
good at what you do they should be
spreading the word if they're not
spreading it enough
then
you need to do a better job on the
service side so think of other ways to
add more value to make it work
better faster have a better experience
dealing with you um
i mean
i know you're dealing with a lot of
variables you're dealing with kids who
are sick and who you know often the
parents are messing up and they're not
following the plan so part of it could
just be being you know supportive
understanding helping them feel like
they're not alone
sharing other stories of what people are
doing
uh if they feel like you're going above
and beyond and you're really on their
side
and then it works
they're gonna tell everybody they know
about you
absolutely
and this is across any service-based
business so you look at business
consultants you look at photographers
you look at
lionel's business if he was a solo guy
you know every service based business if
you look at the top people in their
field as a solo shop they're not doing a
lot of marketing
the business comes to them because
they're really good at what they do they
get great results for their clients and
they get a lot of word-of-mouth
referrals coming in
right
um and so
you know if you're kind of stretch i
focus on that and think how can i
provide better service for the people
who i have coming in
think into the longer term it'd be then
okay i want to build a brand i don't
know if i'm going to do product or if
i'm going to have people under me but
you building a personal brand then
becomes important and it's also more
about um
like if you have a personal mission so
for me i love helping entrepreneurs um
like i didn't know you at all and
through lionel here we are talking which
is great but i want to help a billion
entrepreneurs and so that takes
a ton of work and effort and
making like i could i offered to help
you one-on-one and you said hey i'm open
to doing the hangout and other people
being able to watch and listen in as
well so part of what i love doing is
helping inspire entrepreneurs so we're
helping you but people who are watching
and we'll watch later are also going to
gain information
um and so that's part of your bigger
purpose if you feel like
man i just wish all mothers knew this
information
because it can save them
with so much agony
you sound like you know that firsthand
any
you know if you know anything about bed
wedding uh i'm i'm game because that's
what i'm going through with my son right
now he's he's four
um
anyway uh it's such a pain and parents
will
will will pay to get rid of this problem
they knew that there was something to
help them with it i had people refer
uh i think called sleep doulas i don't
know if you consider yourself a doula or
not or what the difference is um the
difference really yeah no difference
it's the same thing yeah same thing yeah
okay so
i had people recommend that to me when
when we were thinking about getting my
son
uh to be able to sleep through the night
we decided to try it ourselves and
unfortunately after a day and a half at
work it was it was a brutal day and a
half
it was a one night and then
the day and then the next night and then
he was fine um but if it didn't work i
probably would have gone
the route of getting
a sleep doula to come out or someone
like you uh and i would be telling my
friends like oh man i'm not sleeping
my son will not sleep i don't know what
to do
right you want something hey you guys
you got to talk to jen she's awesome
she'll help you with this
um
so
i think you have a great
business
opportunity you're providing a hugely
valuable service
it's thinking what more can you do to
provide the value to the customers they
are spreading word of mouth about you i
mean if you're if you've only been in
business for 18 months and you're
getting five new people a week
that's pretty good
yeah i'm grateful
don't beat yourself up that's that's a
good that's a good start
you have something that works the people
who've been in business for that long
and struggle to get anything coming in
um so what you have
is working
uh just keep doing that and thinking is
there something that comes to mind of
how you can add more value to the
relationship
or provide better service or
people talking about you naturally not
um
not you calling them say hey do you know
any other moms who
could use my services
right
i i'm really big on cards i often send
cards for birthdays thanks for the
referral i'm really big on the
handwritten cards after the fact
um you know keeps me in touch with them
and they're often you know prompted to
then let me know how their child's
sleeping how they're doing if there's
any issues i can quickly give them tips
to help their
uh you know and the unlimited support is
pretty big too i know a lot of
consultants that won't work on weekends
you know they only answer three emails a
day
uh you know i'm pretty available um you
know and i consider that a good thing i
think others
there i think you cut out for stuck in
there
hi
yeah okay now i got you back sorry i
don't know what happened there
um i was just saying i think yeah
weekends you're very available to your
clients
yeah so uh you know i can i consider
that you know one of the alluvids
all you've adds value ads
uh and people appreciate that i get a
lot of good feedback that you know
you're always available um to answer my
questions make me feel comfortable so
that's currently what i'm doing um but
yeah there's definitely room for
improvement you know provide that
additional
um
you know support you know the
encouragement as well
yeah
um
so that's great and that should be
whatever is different between you and
other sleep doulas
should be
highlighted on your site and used in
your language you make it easy for
people to talk about you so if that's if
that's the thing where other superiors
aren't available on the weekend but you
are if you let people know that when
you're talking to them
then it's easy for them to
tell their friends about it too right
like so why is jen different oh well
she's always available she's people on
the weekends
whatever
right you're making it easy for your
clients to talk about you right
um
i like the follow-ups
with with the cards and the birthdays
and and all that it is a good way to
stay top of mind i'm thinking though
like the service itself
yeah
um it's enough to make it
i mean i wish i could make it happen
faster um i encourage them to pick a
method that happens as quick as possible
but you know the success lies in them
being consistent and comfortable with
the plans so sometimes we do pick a
more gradual method that takes a little
bit longer um
but the tough thing with this service is
you know you can't really wait for magic
wand and just make them sleep you know
it is a bit of a process so
i don't know i'd have to think about
that
um yeah
it's hard because you are not in
complete control right you're giving a
system and they have to implement it
yeah what
what might help i'm thinking like some
kind of emergency hotline or something
you know like is there in between
either as part of your value-add or as
part of your initial call like you get
it the one hour is great because you
need to educate right a lot of parents
won't be educated but then the problem
is
when
you're trying it and
like your child is crying and it's not
working or you think it's not working
but it actually is and you're stressed
out like i don't want to hear my child
crying anymore this is crazy
i'm so unhappy you know if there was
that's when i need you
right
if if you kind of talk me off the ledge
right i'm gonna go and i'm gonna go in
and and i just need to comfort him right
and you and you say no right like this
is part of the process stay strong
right or whatever your
whatever your method is um
like that's when i really really really
need you
to help me so how can you build that
into your model i get i i get that
that's part of your overnight package
but is there like an in-between step or
or if i can get a bonus call on top of
my one hour
because that's probably more popular
people would rather do the one hour call
with you
uh than the overnight right
yeah so
you know i do say in my contracts normal
business hours that they can get in
touch with me but typically i sort of
start answering my emails at seven in
the morning until about 11 at night so
it's almost like that's sort of five to
11 is that emergency time where you know
they're trying to implement the plan the
kids not going to sleep at bedtime
um so that's sort of
um and they could you know get in touch
with me or
phone me or something two in the morning
even as like a bonus i don't know like
if they told you that night okay we're
gonna try tonight
right and you're
somewhat available if it's by email or
call something quickly i don't know just
something to think about because that if
you help solve
that problem
in the spot in the moment and walk me
off the ledge i'm going to feel a lot
more like oh my god jen just saved me
right
uh i've got to go i've got to hit up
another google plus call but it was
awesome to meet you and uh and keep me
posted with how you're doing if you have
other questions let me know too i'm
excited for your progress
thank you so much evan you've been so
helpful
all right thank you
in person
bye okay take care